hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be continuing our series in the 1996
duel between Garry Kasparov and deep
blue the supercomputer from IBM I think
this is one of the best games of the
series definitely one I think you're
going to learn a ton if you you know
watch these videos and you enjoy them
that's great
but if you're someone that watches these
and you learn a lot just from you know
the analysis and the commentary I think
this one is going to go above and beyond
as far as learning from you know a
famous chess game which this is so if
you do recall game one was taken by the
supercomputer deep blue game to Garry
Kasparov came back and kicked the crap
out of deep blue to tie it up 1-1 games
three and four actually both ended in a
draw which brings us to game number five
why it's going to be played by the
supercomputer deep blue and blacks going
to be played by Garry Kasparov now do
keep in mind that game six is the last
game so there's only two more games Game
five and six so both sides right now are
tied in points Garry Kasparov knows that
and he also knows that game six he's
going to be playing the white pieces so
early on you're going to see he's gonna
play a very defensive game he has no
problem tying and drawing this game
because he knows going into Game six if
he can pull out a victory then he's
going to win the whole thing and he's
going to have a much easier time winning
his white then he would as black and
it's going to be very very difficult for
him not to at least drawl in game six
with white pieces so do keep that in
mind obviously Garry Kasparov is one of
the greatest tactical players ever to
play the game but early on you do see a
very I don't want to say passive but
very defensive defense so do keep that
in mind but we'll go ahead and get
started into the game deep blue white
starts out with pawn to e4 and Garrick
spot defends with pawn to e5 play
continues with Knight to f3 simple
development move trying to control the
center of the board typically Knights
are going to be coming out before
bishops as far as development always
want to be developing your minor pieces
towards the center gear spot plays
Knight to f6
this is the Petrov defense but it's
going to shift into the four Knights
defense as you'll see white now plays
Knight to c3 and blacks going to respond
with Knight to c6 now do keep in mind
obviously there are tons and tons of
famous games out there with top level
players and you can kind of go in to
databases and see you know what
percentage white wins what percentage
black wins what percentage you actually
draw in these high level games for the
four Knights game which this defense is
there's actually a 68% chance that Garry
Kasparov is either going to tie or win
the game is black so again he has no
problem obviously winning but even so a
tie that's fantastic news for him so he
definitely found the defense that you
know overall this is going to be very
very safe for him he can't get into a
lot of troubles there there's not a lot
of crazy tactical lines that he has to
be worried about so he's going to play
very safe and just see what the computer
gives them so just keep that in mind
from here White's going to continue with
pawn to d4 starting to put up his pawns
trying to put a little pressure on the
center of the board blacks going to take
it back and then why it's going to take
back with his night here on d4 and then
blacks going to bring his bishop down to
b4 now typically you're going to bring
one of your Knights into the game and
then you're going to develop those other
pieces minor or major depending on which
side you want to castle and you
typically want to castle as soon as
possible in this particular case black
is going to bring his bishop out here to
be for pinning down this Knight to c3 a
lot of times you'll see bishops coming
out to actually pin down this Knight to
either the king or the Queen depending
on where it is if it's here on f3 it'll
be pinned down to the Queen so black is
going to be ready to castle on the King
side very very soon now from here
White's going to go ahead and take this
night right here on c6 and black has two
different options he can retake with his
pawn here on c6 or he can take with his
pawn here on d6 now do keep in mind he
does have the option to take it with a
d6 but it's going to be a little bit
tougher for him you know white can
always come and
change queens and then the king comes
here and he could no longer castle now
it's it's not as risky to not castle if
your opponents queen is off the board he
doesn't have as many as weapons to
actually attack your uncle King but
still it's much easier to develop your
pieces to connect your rooks and go into
a middle game and subsequently a better
in-game if you do castle so for this
particular reason black decided to
capture with his pawn here on c6 and
then white played Bishop to d3 again we
already talked about white wants to make
sure that he's developing his pieces he
already has his knight out
now he's developing his lights for a
bishop so they can castle on the King
side and get that King side safety
before he really starts to develop the
rest of his pieces and plan some sort of
attack now white did have a few other
options as far as where he could bring
his bishop but just to kind of go over a
few of those he's definitely not going
to be bringing it to a6 that's a bad
move b5 is going to be losing it as well
sometimes you may see the bishop come
here to c4 going to be attacking this f7
squared which is a huge weakness for
black early on if you've been watching
any of the videos you know why he could
bring it here to e2 but this does kind
of block off some of the protection on
the e4 square he has to keep in mind
that this night here on c3 which is the
current defender of the pawn here on e4
is being pinned down so it definitely
wants to make sure you know this knight
can always come to e4 and capture and
right now white cannot recapture because
the knight pinned down so definitely
wants to make sure he develops this
light square bishop but also is
defending this pawn on e4 now in the
early game you want your minor pieces to
be defending your pawns making sure that
your pawns are very strong in the center
of the board controlling a lot of the
board as you shift into the mid game as
we'll see in this particular game you
want your pawns protecting your pawns
and you want your minor pieces in your
major pieces starting to attack when you
get into the mid game in the late game
you definitely don't want all your
pieces tied down to defending
your pawns that's definitely not what
they need to be doing they need to be
focusing on attacking or developing a
plan to destroy your opponent so for now
this is completely fine definitely want
to make sure the early game you're
defending your pawns as best as possible
from here blacks going to push down with
pawn to d5 black does have double punch
right here but he's going to make it
very easy for himself after white takes
on d5 he's just going to come back here
to d5 and he no longer has those double
pawns there on these heat so as most
games I go over you're typically going
to see both high-level players
developing their pieces not
overextending too much castling to make
sure they have kingside safety so that's
exactly what we are going to continue to
see from both players so deep blue
decides to castle on the kingside garrix
Parv same thing with the black pieces is
going to castle on the King side as well
and now why it's going to bring his
Bishop to g5 this is his last minor
piece getting it involved into the game
obviously pinning down this knight on f6
to the Queen here on d8 so definitely a
nice development moon from him next all
he needs to do is get this Queen
involved to the game connect the rooks
you always want to make sure you connect
your rooks and then white will pretty
much complete the development that he
has now from here black's going to play
pawn to c6 black really has two options
he can bring his Bishop over here to b7
he does need to keep in mind that his
King White's King is no longer you know
calls for worry for this night here on
c3 this Knight is no longer pinned down
so this knight if he wanted to can now
come to d5 at any given time so
eventually black wants to make sure that
this pawn is protected as much as
possible he can either protect it with
the bishop here on b7 or he can protect
it with his pawn here on c6 now again as
we start to move towards the mid game
you typically are going to see pawns
protecting pawns and minor pieces
actually starting to do work so that's
exactly what gierek's Farva does instead
of protecting with his bishop he decides
to move forward with his pawn protecting
this
making a nice little you know solid
structure of the pawns and it's also
going to block off a lot of escape
routes for this night here on c3 so this
night can no longer take he can no
longer come to b5 it's being protected
he could no longer come to e4 so
definitely a nice move to come to c6 and
that's kind of why he did that
so why it's now going to bring his queen
to f3 completing development here and
then black is going to bring his bishop
back to e7 now that the knight is no
longer pinned down he wants to make sure
that they he has enough defenders on
this knight on f6 as we can see the
bishop could always come take here and
if the bishop wasn't here you definitely
don't want to have you know another
double pawn here on the F file and if
the Queen were to come down that's
exactly what would happen after the
exchange so to mitigate that the bishops
just going to come back here to e7 now
if we pause and look at this if we look
at both sides you can see kind of a
distinction but between both so we're
approaching equality white pretty much
has all his pieces developed so all of
his minor pieces major pieces he's
Castle down the King side both of his
rooks are connected so this is very very
good for him if we look at black he
still has to develop his major piece
Queen here the light square Bishop
currently is not doing a whole heck of a
lot granted he can get that involved
very very easy so as far as development
black is actually behind but what he
lacks in development he has a strong
Center control White has lost both his D
pawn and upon very important in the game
you always want to control the center of
the board typically with your pawns if
possible especially early on so black
definitely has a strong center control
which is very very important so although
black does not have all his pieces
developed he still has reached equality
because he has most of his pieces and he
does have some sinner control so a few
things to keep in mind anytime you're
analyzing board trying to figure out
who's who's ahead at the current time
just a few things to look at we'll
continue with the game white plays rook
to e1 anytime there's an open file you
want your
rooks on those open files so that's
exactly what black does is well
and now White's going to bring his
knight back to e twos we talked about
there's not really anything that white
can do here there's no really great
moves or initiative that he has but he
definitely wants to make sure that his
Knights in a better places we talked
about can't come to b5 can't come to a4
I guess it could but you never really
want to have your knight on the edge and
a knight on the rim is brim so he's not
going to be doing a whole lot of good so
sometimes you have to move backwards
before you can move forwards in chess so
the Knights going to come back to e2 so
that he can position it somewhere else
whether that be g3 could always be f4 d4
depending on what the defense gives him
he has a lot more places he could move
around right now he just can't move
anywhere so that's going to come back to
e2 and then blacks going to play pawn to
h6 really a thorn in the side of black
to have this bishop just pinning down
the knight high-level play you're
typically not going to see bishops trade
it off because games can be open so
easily bishop pears just dominate an
open game especially high level so the
bishop is just going to come back not go
into exchange and then the bishop is
going to come to d6 garrix v decides
that he wants to go ahead and exchange
those pieces off and that's fine
and now the Knights going to come to d4
there's no reason to go ahead and
exchange right here kind of gives garry
kasparov a little bit more initiative
his queen would be here on d6 no reason
to kind of give an extra move to garry
kasparov instead he decides to bring his
knight to d4 much better square than it
was here on c3 now blacks going to bring
his a bishop down to g4 not only is he
trying to complete his development but
also gaining tempo forcing this Queen to
move the Queen is not going to come back
over to g3 definitely wants to protect
this bishop here on f4 and also wants to
attack this bishop here on g4
and now the bishops just going to
exchange off after the Queen takes then
the Queen is going to come back over to
b6 this is a great development square as
we've talked about black definitely
wants to make sure he did finishes his
development his last piece to finish his
development was his Queen here on b6
this is not only getting it in
to the game but it's also attacking this
pawn here on b2 and it's attacking this
night here on d4 so really really good
square for the Queen there on b6 white
now plays pawn to c4 and a lot of times
I analyze a lot of games from players
anytime there's a pond exchanges
immediately take and they would in this
particular case take here you definitely
have to keep in mind that you have
strengths and weaknesses right now
strength from black is he has Center
control of the board there's no reason
you kind of lose some of your initiative
and your advantage if let's say you know
the pawn takes an ala the bishop can
retake here on c4 now white starts to
have a little bit more control of the
center of the board black now has this
pawn here on you know the C file that's
not really controlling the center and
now it kind of starts to slip away from
black so there's no reason to go ahead
and take this blacks are just going to
continue moving as pieces but not really
worrying about this pawn here on c4 if
white wants to exchange black has no
problem having a pawn here on d5 that's
a passed pawn now so just keep that in
mind Black's going to play Bishop back
to d6 if we look at this white with his
night here on d4 is attacking this pawn
here on c6 so any time he wants to get
his queen involved into the game he has
to know that this pawn is being attacked
so this Queen back here on g4 is no
longer attacking the Queen it's
developed so you can kind of come back
and kind of protect this pawn in the
meantime before he wants to get it back
involved into the game White's now going
to play pawn takes on d5 and Black's
going to gladly take it back and from
here black has a passed pawn on the D
file this is going to be very very good
for black and it's going to be very
difficult for white because it's just
going to be a huge store in your side
knowing that your opponent has a passed
pawn and the sin of the board and you're
going to have to worry about that
because if that passes you know he's
obviously going to get a queen or
potentially another piece depending on
you know how he wants to destroy you so
why it's now going to play rook takes on
e8 black's going to come back and take
so right now black owns this efile why
it's now going to come to me why it's
going to bring his queen back to d2 and
the bishops now going to come excuse me
the Knights going to come back to e4
attacking this Queen here on D - now the
bishops going to take pretty much
forcing the hand which is exactly what
black wanted and this is an important
note to talk about it if you've seen the
other videos you kind of know this point
but when you approach the in game if you
kind of look at the minor pieces
there's strengths and weaknesses if
there's two sets of pawn chains so in
this case there's a pawn chain over here
upon Island if you will there's pawn
chains on this side of the board so
there's two different sides of the board
bishops do much better because they can
get to both sides of the board very very
quickly if there's just one side of the
board if we took you know the a pawns
off in this B pawn off and there were
just pawns on one side Knights actually
do pretty well because they can maneuver
they don't have to travel all over the
board
so Knights are going to do better in
this particular case bishops are going
to outperform Knights because there's
two pawn islands so Garrick is partly
knew this and he decided hey I have an
opportunity to exchange my knight for
their Bishop heading into the endgame
this is going to be very very good for
me so even in your own game if you're
trying to figure out hey should I
exchange this night or this bishop just
know it really depends on how many pawn
islands you have on the board so side
note but definitely good for anyone
trying to improve their chess game a
tidbit that you definitely want to
incorporate into your own game play
continues with pawn to b3 wants to
solidify this pawn structure here on the
Queen side there's not a lot of pieces
definitely wants to make sure that this
pawn right here on b3 and a2 are kind of
taking care of themselves doesn't really
have to tie any other resources down to
protecting those garrix pause not going
to bring his rook over to d8 in this
particular situation gierek's bach
actually
offered a drawl to deep blue and the
deep blue team and deep blue actually
decline the drawl so they actually
thought that they not only had a winning
position but would actually win the game
they didn't even think they would draw
this so I find that very interesting
obviously there is more time in the
video so you know that it does go on and
garrix Bob ends up winning so I just
find that very interesting that they
would actually take this position which
I actually think is winning for Garry
Kasparov as we talked about with the
bishop and the knight here and they
actually decline that so definitely a
game changer you know going into game
number six it may have changed a little
bit as far as the the preparation garrix
problem could have been played for the
draw but so just a fun fact is we kind
of continue in this game this particular
situation gierek's Bob offered a draw
and it was declined black's going to
play pawn to f5 now again as we talked
about this pawn here on e5 you want to
be protecting it if possible with other
pawns so black starts to smell some fear
here so he's going to start to push
forward and see if he can put a lot of
pressure on white White's going to
respond with rook to d1 definitely wants
to make sure that he doesn't concede
this opened e-file now obviously the
e-file is a semi open file so once make
sure he gets it involved into the open
file black's going to play Bishop to e6
wants to make sure he's still protecting
this pawn here on f5 with his bishop but
also wants to make sure that he has full
access with his rook here on d8 so
really with all these small little moves
just trying to you know increase his
advantage get all of his pieces involved
into the game working together and
that's exactly what he does it's really
interesting that Gary Kasparov just
completely tactically outplayed a
supercomputer since that's exactly what
they're supposed to be good at that's
exactly what your expire about play time
at so very very interesting White's now
going to play bit excuse me Queen to e3
again there's a discovered attack on the
Queen if this Knight moves so just a
heads up there now the bishops going to
come back to f7 and White's now going to
play the Queen back to c3
and then blacks going to start to push
forward putting a lot of pressure again
as we talked about on the kingside and
light decides to bring his rook up to d2
again there's just so much pressure on
white he's going to have to play really
really well to stop all the attacks from
black now play continues with the black
queen coming over to f6 want to make
sure he's protecting this pawn here on
f4 he's going to start pushing so he
wants to make sure you as all his pieces
ready now the pawns are going to come up
to d3 trying to put some counter-attack
here on this f4 square rooks now going
to come down to d5 and the pawn is going
to come to a 3 now the pawn a 3 to me is
kind of a question mark doesn't really
do a whole lot of good white really
needs to be improving his position a
little bit more I don't really know what
he's trying to accomplish with pawn to
a3 seems like a questionable call to me
but you know supercomputer tactically
supposed to be really good so I'm sure
the computer saw something that I did
not from here the the King's going to
come over to h7 Garrigus bar has full
intent to start to trade down and get
into an endgame once you approach the in
game your King becomes a very very
valuable asset you want to make sure
he's involved into the game so with that
said the King is now going to be coming
to you know h7 eventually to g6 to f5
wants to make sure that he centralized
so he can join the fight
once pieces start to fall off the board
now the White King comes to g2 which
he's starting to think the exact same
thing but this in particular is probably
a bad move I would have liked to see
something like h3 and then you know he
could have always brought it his king
over to h2 I think that would have been
better than King to g2 just doesn't do a
whole lot of good for him but that's
what he decided to play now Black's
going to play Queen to e5 putting a lot
more pressure now also defending you
know this pawn here on f4 but also
attacking this diagonal and then
starting to open
the door for this King to get involved
into the game so the pawn is now going
to come to f3 and Garrick's barb decides
I'm not even going to exchange instead
I'm going to start to push forward which
anytime you have a passed pawn pass
pawns were meant to be pushed so if
you're ever looking at a game and you
have a passed pawn you're like I just
have no clue what the crap I'm supposed
to do just push your passport happens
from here white plays rook to d3 the
pawn is just continued to be pushed
white decides to go ahead and take on f4
attacking the Queen garrix barb does not
care at all he's going to continue to
push comes down promotes to a queen
after the exchange here he's going to
come back take the Queen after the rook
takes he's going to take the rook here
on d4 so as you can see a couple things
obviously White has more pawns he has
two more pawns but White has not only a
bishop but he has the most powerful
minor piece going into the endgame again
to pawn islands definitely going to be a
lot stronger with the bishop because it
can just move all over the place now
best case scenario which garrix Bob's
going to try to get to is if he can take
off these rooks this is pretty much the
last threat that White has so if he can
get these he can pretty much move all
over the game and just gobble up pawns
if he wants to it's going to be
virtually impossible for white to stop
the onslaught of a bishop from garrix
prop so white now plays pawn to b4 and
black plays a very important move and he
plays Bishop to c4 now if you look at it
he wants to immobilize this rook as much
as possible again this is the last hope
for white and that's exactly what Bishop
to c4 does this stops this rook from
moving past the fourth-ranked he can no
longer do anything productive and this
is going to also make it a lot easier
for gira Kasparov to exchange off the
rooks off the board so very very
important move this small little Bishop
to c4 very very good move
leading into the in-game which obviously
as we talked about is going to be very
very easy for Derek's prof to win we'll
go ahead and finish up the game here the
king is going to come to f2 wants to
make sure that he tries to get that King
involved into the game centralize it a
little bit more blacks going to bring
his pawn over to g5 wants to push a
little bit further further before he
gets his King devolve into the game the
white rook is going to come over to e3
try to really escape but there's really
a nod of action a lot of bad action that
he can do but this particular case wants
to go ahead and bring his rook behind
this past pawn that he has you're on in
efj I've make sure that if there is any
potential he can kind of push that
forward blacks going to kind of forward
that he's going to bring his Bishop back
to e6 stopping this pawn for me pushing
you further the Brooks thing to come
back to c3 trying to get out there and
the bishops kind of gum pack to see for
now
well when the rook comes back to e3
gierek's fobs now going to bring his
rook kind of it in between move he's
going to check the King here on f2 and
then the King is going to come back here
to e1 from here the rooks going to come
up to d3 trying to exchange off these
rooks right here he knows going into the
endgame he has a much favorable position
so if you can go ahead and exchange off
these last rooks on the board it's going
to be an easy win for garrix prov now
the white king is going to come back to
f2 black decides to go ahead and
centralize his King a little bit before
he does exchange these pieces off so the
rooks are going to come off the board
the white king is now going to come to
e3 the bishop comes back to c2 more
centralization from both squares and
then garrix power plays pawn to h5 &
white resigns now if you can look at it
if you're not too familiar with why
people resign if you look at this Garry
Kasparov has this LightSquared bishop
here on c2 at any time he could always
bring it to b3 cutting off this e six
squared but more importantly anytime he
wants he can always bring this Bishop to
a4 attacking in protecting the square on
EA tiff he ever wanted to he could
always you know bring it here and bring
it back to g6 if you really had to if
the King started to get involved and
started attacking that Bishop but
there's no way he can always exchange
this Bishop for this pawn it
doesn't matter for black because the
King can now come down to f4 he can go
ahead and start gobbling up all these
pieces if the black king or sues me if
the white King tries to kind of hold on
to these then Bobby Fischer can just
chase him around the board with the
Bishop and then he can go ahead and
gobble up this pawn here on e5 so it's
going to be virtually impossible
garrix bob just has an overwhelming
advantage and there's no way for white
to really continue and not lose this
game so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video there's a ton of fantastic
material to learn in this video so
hopefully you're not only enjoyed
watching it but hopefully you actually
learn something can apply it to your own
chess game and you can actually see
improvement in your own chess game so
definitely let me know what you guys
think of the video and I will see you
guys in game number six and the 1996
series between Garry Kasparov and deep
blue